[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de ce lundi 2 octobre c'était un
scrutin sans surprise après la victoire
des républicains aux sénatoriales
l'yvelinois gérard larcher a été réélu
cet après-midi président du sénat c'est
le troisième mandat de l'ancien maire de
rambouillet à la tête de la haute
assemblée
réactions après les titres de sophie
primas sénatrice l ère des yvelines
la ville de guyancourt continue sa mue
de nouveaux aménagements viennent d'être
inaugurés au quartier du pont du route
voire 150 logements dont une nouvelle
résidence sur l'emplacement d'une
ancienne école
reportage dans ce journal et puis c'est
un rallye 100% féminin la 7e édition du
cap fémina aventure débute jeudi et 12
jours de rencontres et de périple à
travers le désert marocain
2 yvelinoise participent à l'événement
emilie martin et lots nord langis nyon
et nous les recevons sur ce plateau là
était l'information a été confirmée en
début d'après midi elle était attendue
gérard larcher a été une nouvelle fois
désigné président du sénat l'élu
yvelinois les républicains se retrouve à
la tête de la chambre aux 348
parlementaire pour la troisième fois
après une élection en 2008 et en 2014
une haute assemblée largement à la tête
à droite après la victoire des
républicains aux sénatoriales
mais gérard larcher est un homme qui
fait consensus d'après sophie primas
sénatrice l ère des yvelines c'est une
très bonne nouvelle pour le sénat gérard
larcher fait leur territoire elop du
territoire les villes messieurs des
territoires en france dans leur
diversité
moi je suis frappé pour avoir fait
plusieurs déplacements avec lui rina la
considération des élus locaux quelle que
soit leur étiquette politique à son
égard
les locaux ont bien compris puisque
gérard larcher vraiment un homme qui est
contrôlé et c'est un homme qui est
passionné par le sénat il est pour ça qu
c'est déjà pas mal d'années de sa vie
politique
les passionnés par ce lien au territoire
est vraiment aujourd'hui la diction qui
s'est affaissé de fer comprend
dro français à quel point le pique nique
est important pour ce scrutin gérard
larcher a reculé à 2 123 voix sur 348 il
avait face à lui aujourd'hui deux
présidents de groupe au sénat le
socialiste didier guillaume et la
communiste
eliane assassi politique toujours lé
député des yvelines prennent leurs
marques sur le territoire il y a
quelques jours hors berger élus lrm sur
la 10e circonscription a inauguré sa
permanence parlementaire à rambouillet
une ouverture devant 200 personnes et en
présence du secrétaire d'état belge en
un gris vos reportages de nicolas
kirillovitch pédagogie et soutient
l'objectif était double pour le
secrétaire d'état en déplacement à
rambouillet pédagogie économique d'abord
avec la rencontre de plusieurs
entrepreneurs sur le campus smartcity
quelques jours seulement après la
présentation du budget 2010 8 les
acteurs économiques locaux ont profité
de ce déplacement pour interpeller l'un
des proches du président de la
république essaye tous les jours de
développer sa société dette au plus près
ses salariés a et c est le retour
d'avoir un ministre est très important
ça permet effectivement d'avoir plus de
visibilité d'avoir les deux et puis et
puis le soutien s'est déjà cdh soutien
en termes d'imagés pour nous c'est déjà
très positifs et puis bon je posais
attendre les questions que j'espère
qu'on aura les réponses à l'avenir ces
chefs d'entreprise pourront directement
interroger aurore bergé député de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines
la jeune élue a inauguré sa permanence
parlementaire sur le campus rambolitains
lors de la campagne présidentielle
howard berger fut l'une des premières
politiques de droite a quitté le navire
ait l'air pour rejoindre celui de la
république en marche
à l'époque fait d'avoir un peu de
courage et le courage dans la période
c'est un peu d'indispensable parce que
vous prenez pas la mer par gros temps
avec des gens qui au premier coup de
vent vous laisse tomber ou auprès de
mabri et ce tir du bateau en faire des
permanences tournant dans une dizaine de
villes de la circonscription
on va aller à la rencontre de nos
concitoyens parce que c'est trop changé
aussi l'état d'esprit c'est pas à eux de
prendre rendez vous pour venir à nous
c'est à nous de venir à leurs trousses
elle la nouvelle permanence sera
notamment ouvert tous les mardis sans
rendez vous entre 10h et 17h nous vous
l'annoncions la semaine dernière quatre
mille caméras anti-attentats vont être
déployés sur le territoire par le
conseil départemental dispositifs
intelligents s'enclenche ans au moindre
mouvement un dispositif un projet que
condamnent à la liga des droits de
l'homme des yvelines dans un communiqué
elle dénonce un système dangereux pour
les libertés pouvant entendre des
conversations la ldh 78 demande
l'abandon pur et simple du dossier et
que les crédits soit attribuée à
d'autres opérations à l'automne a
commencé il ya une dizaine de jours le
début de la saison qui est aussi la
période des vendanges dans les régions
viticoles à elancourt également aux
récoltent le raisin
hier se déroulait donc cette vendange au
clos du mousseau le clos du mousseau qui
est gérée par l'association des amis du
passé d'elancourt une trentaine
d'enfants étaient présents au programme
cueillette des grappes foulage de
raisins avec les pieds puis et
dégustation des premières gouttes de jus
interview de nicolas landry
l'aboutissement de tout un travail d de
l'équipe d'avignon avec un travail
hebdomadaire de quelques heures et puis
des traitements des décès pour éviter
les maladies rugueux milieu piocher et
effeuiller les faits les vignes la
récolte va servir à produire du vin
blanc et rouge ainsi que du jus de
raisin et début de l'automne donc
l'heure est au bilan et à la préparation
de l'hiver pour les agriculteurs avec
près de
200 vaches et 400 hectares de cultures
la ferme de grillons à thiverval grignon
et déjà prête
nicolas landry c'est l'heure du petit
déjeuner pour les vaches laitières de la
ferme de grignon au menu des cultures
fourragères
chez nous la ration est composé en base
on va dire cette l'ensilage de maïs donc
à peu près un tiers de
un tiers du mélange qu'une plante riche
en énergie mais assez pauvre en
protéines on met de la luzerne aussi il
ya beaucoup de luzerne chez nous c'est
un gros quart de la ration herbe luzerne
maïs les fourrages sont stockés toute
l'année à l'extérieur la préparation et
le mélange des ingrédients sont
minutieux dans une tablette numérique
sur le sur le tracteur qui n'oublie la
quantité à m parent par aliments par lot
de vaches et dès qu'on atteint en
quantité on arrête de la mixture est
ensuite distribuée aux bêtes elles en
consomment près de 23 kg par jour une
quantité nécessaire pour la production
du lait des vaches
aucun changement dans le traitement des
animaux de la ferme même en hiver les
vaches ont rarement froid leur
température idéale c'est 5 degrés
température extérieure
donc c'est pour ça que voyez que le
bâtiment là est très ouvert parce que
finalement le rumen il fait beaucoup de
chaleur et elle cherche à se débarrasser
quelque part de cette chaleur du côté
des céréales la récolte 2010 est est
jugée précoce mais de qualité pour
l'hiver la ferme de grignon a déjà
planté du colza spécifique pour la
saison le colza pour l'instant n'est pas
très développé bien pris mais continue à
se développer pour son humour si refaire
plus de feuilles avant l'hiver
il va entre en dormance pour l'hiver et
puis repartira au printemps est assez
rapidement ici à partir de fin mars
début avril on peut commencer à voir les
premières fleurs de colza avec une bonne
récolte du colza en 2017 malgré quelques
doutes
la ferme de grignon espère faire aussi
bien en 2010 8 à guyancourt le pont du
route voire évolué l'aménagement du
quartier et se poursuit clinique mais
son inter générationnelle logement les
réalisations sont nombreuses
une nouvelle résidence vient d'ailleurs
d'être inaugurée sur l'emplacement d'une
ancienne école les précisions de mélanie
poquet l'ancien groupe scolaire a laissé
place à une nouvelle résidence le
quartier du pont du rotois re poursuit
sa mue cette nouvelle résidence est
composée de 49 logements
c'est une résidence qu'on a acquis en
vefa vente en état futur d'achèvement
auprès d'eiffage qui ces composants
trois plots
van ky deux plots pour du parent social
et un plot qui est uniquement en
accession à la propriété chien l'un des
programmes et mixe avec du logement très
social social et intermédiaire et
l'autre plus haut il uniquement logement
intermédiaire une nouvelle étape dans la
rénovation du quartier lancé en 2006 une
volonté de la commune de dynamiser ce
quartier né en 1974
c'est l'idée de construire la ville sur
la ville on a construit donc de nouveaux
logements
une nouvelle école une clinique tout ça
voilà tout tous ses atouts et l'a donc
c'était une des parts l'avant dernière
tranche de cette opération donc 250
logements qui était construit sur
l'ancien emplacement de l'école dur sa
prochaine étape de cette rénovation une
résidence intergénérationnelle qui
devrait voir le jour en 2018
le sport et cette prestation de haute
volée un record mondial a été établi
samedi au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
à 82 ans jeannette augusto a parcouru
plus de 28 km en 1h un exploit pour une
cycliste de son âge le récit de cette
performance avec nicolas landry jabra
vous ça a été magnifique équilibre
c'est un magnifique et squash procès
pour voies lors elle ne pensais pas
réaliser cette performance mais elle l'a
fait à 82 ans jeannette augusto a établi
le record du monde féminin de leurs des
plus de 80 ans avec une distance
parcourue de 28 km 226 très contente et
puis pas fatigué ça a été moins dure 15
mercredi dernier
voilà super super son entraîneur de
l'équipe cycliste de vélizy jean michel
richefort a guidé jeannette sur la piste
des indications de temps et d
encouragement pour donner le rythme et
atteindre l'objectif
oui j'ai douté au début parce que j'en
étais parti très vite donc bien au delà
du tableau de marche
elle tournait en moins de 30 secondes au
tour alors que nous avions fixé 32
secondes au tour
j'avais peur qu'après un quart d'heure
elle fléchissent et jeannette elle ne
s'est jamais désuni elle a toujours
rouler régulièrement
et puis elle n'a jamais fléchi surtout
pour la soutenir dans son épreuve les
supporters sont venus de loin notamment
de rois le village où réside jeannette
en franche-comté encourager notre star
royaux lot et qui est extraordinaire a
franchement super génial m'a épaté m'a
étonné l'a vraiment ouais c'est bien
payé pour le public les accompagnateurs
et tout c'est formidable je m'attendais
pas à ça c'est une surprise pour
jeannette les records s'est terminée
elle va pouvoir retourner un roi en
reine du cyclisme et continuer le vélo
avec passion c'est un rallye sportif
mais aussi solidaire et particularité il
est 100% féminin est la septième édition
du cap fémina aventure débute jeudi et
12 jours de rencontres et de périple à
travers le désert marocain jusqu'au 14
octobre
elle nous recevons sur ce plateau un
diot de participantes elles sont
yvelinoise c'est l'équipage 311 baptisé
et les faits merida ma droite il y à
emilie martin bonsoir dans sa note le
professeur des écoles à elancourt et à
ma gauche et au nord roland gillon
bonsoir ça journaliste de profession
alors c'est la première participation
pour toutes les deux à ce rallye
première question pourquoi se lancer
dans cette aventure
emilie peut-être pour commenter pourquoi
se lancer dans cette aventure
à vrai dire j'ai eu 40 ans cette année
donc ça a été le facteur déclencheur à
20 ans j'avais traversé le pacifique à
la voile et du coup je me suis dit que
je souhaitais mes 40 ans il fallait
faire quelque chose
voilà ça faisait à peu près 20 ans je
pense qu'on en parlait avec ma copilote
on se disait un jour on ira faire un
rallye dans le désert et donc voilà ça
arrive donc est une femme baluchon
on espère qu'on essaye de rester et vous
d'autres côté l'honore pourquoi se
lancer dans l'aventuré
ben moi je suis une fan de deux voitures
en général j'étais toujours devant la
formule 1 quand j'étais plus jeune
et en fait quand j'ai fait mon stage
chez hervé en fin d'études j'ai
découvert le rallye des gazelles et je
me suis toujours dit que j'allais le
faire et j'ai été poussé par ml cette
année donc
et j'ai aussi 40 ans donc ça tombe très
bien alors il ya eu celle des gazelles
qui est un rallye dans dans le même
genre les ces mêmes organisateurs mêmes
organisateurs
c'est une première étape très bien alors
c'est la particularité de ce rallye
c'est qu'il ya donc un côté sportif 1200
km de pistes à parcourir à l'aide d'un
road book d'une boussole et de votre 4,4
me aussi cet aspect solidaire des
actions qui sont menées en france et qui
vont être menées également au maroc
c'est aussi ça peut-être qu'il vous a
plu le côté sportif et solidaire ça mais
les deux thématiques
oui c'était vraiment le mixte le mélange
d'avoir des deux
l'idée qu'on allait là bas mais qu'on a
on y allait pour quelque chose aussi
même si on y va pour se dépasser
on a envie de rendre service sur place
et donc c'était assez séduisant et
donc on nous on a une action en france
on devait collecter du matériel de
puériculture pour l'association les
laisse courir les du coeur et du coup on
va emmener des vêtements également au
maroc qu'on va distribuer plus repeindre
une école directement sur place
il est alors important que vous avez
traversé le pacifique
ces défis sportifs c'était important
pour vous aussi d'apporter ce côté
solidaire à une aventure
bah oui parce que c'est vrai que c'est
un peu exceptionnel ce qu'on fait à
partir comme ça pendant quinze jours et
du coup c'est vrai que je trouve ça
important de pouvoir rendre service même
si on va pas forcément révolutionner
voilà les choses
je pense que c'est important d'être
disponible pour les autres et d'essayer
d'apporter un petit peu sa petite touche
voilà solidaire alors vous parliez de
ces collectes qui sont réalisés en
france et pour l'association des restos
bébés du coeur c'est quoi comme type de
matériel puériculture matériel de
puériculture a cédé l'idée des parcs
tout ce qui est nécessaire un bébé y en
a pas besoin de pas mal de choses vous
étiez d'ailleurs à versailles samedi
pour cette collecte avec avec votre 4,4
également c'est ça comment ça s'est
passé ça te coller que bien accueillie
par les versaillais avait super bien
vous avez vraiment couragement de gens
qui plaçaient qui ont trouvé notre 4,4
magnifique déjà voit les images de cette
manifestation c'est et les gens étaient
hyper gentil père enfin nous encourager
vraiment et du coup ça nous a bien
boosté par l'idée c'était de récolter ce
matériel pour l'association des restos
bébés du coeur c'était aussi de
sensibiliser peut-être le public autour
d'une association vous portez que vous
défendez c'est l'association pour un
sourire c'est exactement
donc c'est une association qui a été
créée par des familles versaillaise
équivalent ouvrir une structure pour
adolescents autistes
parce qu'aujourd'hui mayas ont tout le
monde le sait mais c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment dur pour toutes ces familles il
ya vingt mille enfants qui sont pas pris
en charge
actuellement vingt mille a surtout une
majorité d'adolescents et donc l'école
est obligatoire pour tous les enfants
sauf pour les enfants autistes et donc
rien qu'à versailles a neuf enfants qui
sont chez eux toute la journée et qui
sont sans solution
donc voilà c'est vraiment la double
peine pour pour tous ses parents parce
que non seulement c'est quand même
compliqué d'avoir un enfant autiste et
en plus c'est la croix et la bannière
pour eux c'est la lutte vraiment c'est
vraiment une minute pour trouver des
structures il manque des places donc là
l'association qu'on soutient qu'ils
s'appellent pour un sourire a déposé un
dossier auprès de la sécurité sociale et
donc il faut avoir une réponse en
octobre pour savoir si oui ou non ils
vont enfin pouvoir ouvrir leur structure
alors parce qu'en fait le nerf de la
guerre c'est scellés sont clairement
c'est l'argent et le budget c'est 5000
euros donc ça paraît une grosse somme
comme ça mais en fait les liens que
l'éducation nationale consacre huit
mille euros par an pour chaque collégien
donc si l'état donne est la même chose
qu est ce qui donne un enfant normal il
y aurait déjà 75% du budget qui serait
bouclée donc
là on espère on croise les doigts et on
espère que la sécurité sociale va donner
l'autorisation pour l'ouverture de cette
structure actions menées en france mais
aussi des choses qui seront faites sur
place au maroc ça sera de quel type
ces actions solidaires du coup on va
distribuer le matériel qu'on aura
apporté enfin les vêtements et matériel
scolaire je crois qu'il ya un peu de
médical aussi les du divers produits
d'hygiène et on fait surtout repeindre
une école donc c'est à el fida
j'ai pas trop quand vous savez j'ai
voilà et et pourtant j'ai étudié le
terrain mais voilà justement j'allais
vous parlez du côté sportif le troisième
équipier de cette aventure c'est bien
sûr votre 4 4 comment ça s'est passé
vous avez dû l'acheter on vous l'a
fourni le 4 4 comment comment ça s'est
passé à leur nom à vrai dire il ya
quelqu'un au départ qu'il voulait nous
prêté gentiment son 4 4 mais voilà on il
n'était pas en assez bon état et pour
une première participation s'était un
peu bête de se retrouver bloqué à
fontainebleau
du coup on a loué on a loué un 4 4
iliad et désorganisent qui sont
spécialisées dans la location de deux
voitures pour les rallyes vous avez une
aide médias libres vous avez dû
apprendre quelques notions oui à la
réparer ses besoins ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'on a appris à changer des roues à
utiliser les plaques de désensablage on
connaît à peu près où sont les filtres
etc
on a on a un petit paquet avec des
pièces de rechange habituel par contre
au niveau mécanique on s'y connaît
certainement pas et met sur place et des
mécanos qui si on a les pièces en tout
cas peuvent faire à notre place
un petit tour de table avant de terminer
cet entretien côté sportif on l'a dit
1200 km de piste a traversé avec une
boussole et est un road book et bien sûr
à bord de votre 4,4 à j moins de du
départ quel est le ressenti est
confiante
moi je suis un petit peu stressé parce
que déjà on parle quinze jours j'ai on
laisse nos enfants enfin voila c'est
bête mais bon ça fait aussi en plus
voilà je pense qu'il ya de l'excitation
est un peu d'appréhension
et puis voilà on a peur d'être fatigué
de lire est ce que vous voilà c'est il
faut vraiment tenir physiquement jours
parce que je crois que c'est surtout ça
qui est dur c'est que normal voilà après
je suis très très content j'ai vraiment
ravi d'être arrivé jusqu'au bout parce
que ça a été ça a été quand même un
parcours long et voilà ça a été quand
même le nom de récolter tout le budget
voilà ça a été ça a été une vraie
expérience et en même temps on a appris
plein de choses
donc non très content très très
rapidement et lorsqu'on a dépassé le
temps excitation et appréhension c'est
le même appareil
pareil avec
voit vraiment une super excitation même
si je pense qu'on ne s'attende on sait
pas du tout comment ça va se passer sur
place et bien bon courage et bonne
chance à vous deux je le rappelle donc
elle honore l'angine u11 à gauche et
lili martin à ma droite vous êtes tous
les participants au rallye cap fémina
aventure sous les couleurs de l'équipage
311 et ce radical aventure c'est du 4 au
14 octobre au maroc plus d'informations
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran sport toujours le sky
rugby faisait hier son retour en
division d'honneur trois ans après
l'avoir quittée et le club a bien lancé
sa saison victoire à domicile face à
l'entente aimante limay score final de
23 à 22
le résumé du match de nicolas landry
[Applaudissements]
c'est la pénalité de la gagne pour le
sky rugby un succès sur le fil 23 à 22
face à l'entente mainteni mai une
victoire importante pour les saint
quentinois promu en division honneur
cette saison
ça fait du bien de revenir avec une
victoire et c'est vrai que moi à
l'époque j'étais j'étais pas au sky le
capitaine y était et son mode fin de
match c'est à dire que vous avez fait
deux saisons sans aucune victoire en
honneur et de recommencer à landivisiau
heures par une victoire ça fait du bien
à tout le monde au moral
pourtant rien n'a été simple dans cette
partie une des conditions climatiques
compliquées pas de grandes envolées un
ballon glissant les fautes de mains se
multiplient avec l'indiscipliné des deux
équipes la première période s'est
résumée à un duel de buteurs
à la mi-temps m'incliner mène 12 à 6 on
a commencé le vent dans le nez pour un
peu plus de fraîcheur en premières
minutes on voulait en première mi temps
on voulait tenir le ballon et essayer de
relancer à la main et ont séduit en
deuxième mi temps on aura le vent dans
don pourra sortir de chez nous un peu
plus au pied au retour des vestiaires
les nantais sont réduits à 14 ils
encaissent directement un premier essai
[Musique]
et suite à une touche à l'entrée des 22
mètres le bus de skype envers ses
joueurs montés pour doubler la mise
[Applaudissements]
à dix minutes de la fin les hommes de
thomas payen men 20 à 12
mais les mantais réagissent et puis y
mettre une pénalité un quart d'heure de
la fin ils reviennent à cinq points et
dans les cinq dernières minutes une
touche il avance on fait une faute une
deuxième touché ils finissent dans
l'en-but 2 qui termine devant trois
minutes de la fin on est un peu en un
peu sous pression pour les dernières
minutes la pression les saint quentinois
l'ong gérés pour finalement l'emporter
une expérience acquise pour le
déplacement de dimanche prochain à cergy
pontoise pour le compte de la deuxième
journée de la division honneur et didier
deschamps dominique rocheteau ou encore
sonny anderson c'est une pluie de gloire
d'anciennes gloires du football qui sera
présente à poissy pour la bonne cause le
variétés club de france affronte la
sélection geodis mercredi 11 octobre au
stade léo lagrange coup d'envoi 19h
match caritatif au profit d'associations
les footballeurs qui n'hésitait pas à se
mobiliser d'après ses propos recueillis
par wilfrid richy et nicolas
kirillovitch le joueur de football
que ce soit sa notoriété planétaire ou
notoriété quelque part un petit peu
normal sont des gens qui sont une
générosité
vous ne pouvez pas imaginer et moi je le
dis parce que je le sais parce que je
les ai pratiqués et jamais j'étais déçu
prix des billets de 5 à 10 euros vous
pouvez les réserver à l'avant sous les
acheter le jour j dans la limite des
places disponibles
on referme cette page sports sur du
golfe et la ryder cup qui s'exporte
également dans les classes depuis la
rentrée trente mille élèves de cm1-cm2
apprennent leur cours de manière ludique
à travers un livre est baptisé mon
carnet de golf à voisins le bretonneux
une classe a adopté ce dispositif créé
par la fédération française de golf
saint quentin en yvelines et l'éducation
nationale michel et nidau
cet après midi dans cette classe de
voisins-le-bretonneux session
particulière les élèves et leurs
professeurs utilisent mon carnet de golf
un programme éducatif créé dans le cadre
de la ryder cup 2018 la coupe du monde
de la discipline qui s'organisait à
saint quentin en yvelines
objectif apprendre de façon ludique les
matières scolaires
on a d'autres thèmes généraux départ
découvrir le golf et découvrir la ryder
cup
donc je découvre je progresse
j'approche et je retiens lorsque les
enfants ont parcouru donc ces pages ils
ont déjà une culture assez étendue par
rapport au thème c'est c'est vraiment
bénéfique
après avoir testé la première version du
carnet de golf en 2015 la professeur n'a
pas hésité à renouveler l'expérience
pour cette nouvelle année scolaire afin
de stimuler les élèves
c'est évident que d'avoir en fil rouge
un projet dans la classe qui plus est un
projet sportif parce que les enfants
aiment beaucoup le sport a beaucoup
d'activités sportives
ça permet vraiment de calais d
apprentissage sans que la difficulté ou
tout ce qui est trop abstrait où tout ce
qui est trop technique ne prenne le
dessus des apprentissages qui se font
tout seuls sans que les élèves ne soient
bloqués par l'aspect trop théorique en
fait d apprentissage une recette qui
fonctionne les 26 élèves de cette classe
plébiscitent ce programme d'enseignement
créée par la fédération française 50 en
libye n'est l'éducation nationale de
l'anglais un peu de mal
ça nous apprend les règles du golf à
steam play c'est que on travaille en
même temps parce que c'est marrant on va
dire que ça va prendre plusieurs choses
à la fois donc c'est marrant en même
temps et comment fait il ya plusieurs
maintien du combat l'après midi s'est
terminé par une cession de golf
l'occasion de mettre en pratique leurs
acquis de s'entraîner en vue de fouler
le green de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
une sortie scolaire est programmée d'ici
la fin de l'année fin de la page sport
et aussi afin de ce set 8 journal sur tv
78 merci de l'avoir suivi nos reportages
et le replay sont disponibles sur notre
application mobile tv 78 ou sur notre
site internet
bonne soirée et excellente semaine à
tous
[Musique]